as always seems to happen when you
appear on the show i have a list of
questions on your brief as long as my
arm but but i hope we can start just
briefly on on that which we are hearing
at the flu vaccination program clearly
there are a lot of concerns about the
pressures that could be brought to bed
on the health service given restrictions
are pretty much gone covert is in the
community and and flu will be increasing
just how bad do we think things could
get
i think it's extremely important that
people
get their flu vaccination in previous
years we will have heard these messages
pre covered and some people thought well
you know i'm usually fine with these
things this year is different as your
report suggested you've had people not
building up any immunity because last
year we were all split apart so much uh
because of covid
and then the obviously the twin threats
are both covid uh and flu means that
this year getting your flu jab if you're
in any one of the many different
categories you you showed there all over
50s vulnerable people people who live
with vulnerable people just go and get
the flu jab done you can probably get it
at the same time or similar time to
doing the booster uh jab for people for
covert as well
some of those involved in in the health
service are suggesting we could see
deaths from flu rising as high as sixty
thousand
well look i'm not a epidemiologist even
though we've all become our armchair
once through uh through the covid uh
crisis but we know the dangers of flu
it's not new that pressures on the
health service every single year uh
through uh the winter months due to flu
and yes last year was really just an
exception to that because of people
staying at home so uh but we can all do
something about it and of course the flu
vaccine as that is that thing um so you
know
when you get the call um please go and
get the jab as has been so familiar with
cobi kovid but now for flu as well
let's both take off our amateur
epidemiologists hats and move directly
on to your brief and of course a big
announcement yesterday in terms of uh
travel around the world just seven
countries now uh left on the red list
and some people are suggesting however
that we should still be concerned about
the possibility of variants coming into
this country and perhaps seeding is is
that not a major concern of the
government anymore
well you're right so it's a major step
forward um really the travel industry
which has been into this crisis first
out last in many ways has suffered
hugely that's a lot of jobs on the line
etc
when it comes to the safety aspect of it
we are still requiring a test we're
going to move that down from being a pcr
test the the expensive ones that you
have to send away to our lab to a
lateral flow test so that will help and
it will enable us to monitor things and
actually reassuringly if you come back
from somewhere you do a lateral flow you
get a positive
then you'll be able to get a free nhs
pcr test in the normal way and you're
back into the normal system but the big
difference of course now is we're
vaccinated and if we're having this
conversation this time last year no one
was vaccinated and that really makes the
change here
just in terms of the testing and the
move from pcr to lateral flow can can
you give us a date on when we might know
this of course half term is fast
approaching there are plenty of people
who might not be able to afford to get
away for a break if we're talking about
a requirement for a pcr rather than a
lateral flow test yeah that's right we
want to get this done for half term for
people i know my colleagues over at
health
and to a certain extent extend the home
office they're the people who have to
implement this this change uh working
extremely hard on uh getting this done
uh and so we anticipate having it ready
uh for the half term
and what a difference it will make for
people rather than having to
do things like send off the test and
wait for the result as people will be
familiar with a lateral flow you read it
on the cassette there and then it shows
your result within a you know a few
minutes uh and much much easier much
less expensive as well
just just very briefly when might we
expect that announcement then
uh in the coming days we know when
obviously the half terms coming up and
my advice to people would be um just to
to hold off you will need to book one of
the make sure that you've got a lateral
flow uh tester booked and you'll you'll
put the the reference number on your
passenger locator form before you come
home of course you can fill that out
whilst you're abroad in most cases uh
and of course another simplification is
and it's already happened you no longer
need to take a test before you depart
wherever you're coming back from spain
or wherever you happen to be back to the
uk you no longer need to seek a test
before you come here so that's a major
simplification because the big one we're
waiting for in november this won't be
for half term i'm afraid but the us have
said that they'll reopen to uh british
visitors as well of course that's a very
major air route the busiest in the world
do we have a specific date on that just
yet uh transport secretary i don't i
i've been speaking to my opposite number
i spoke to the american ambassador a
couple of days ago they're still working
through the technicalities of that
they've said november uh to us and
obviously we're working very closely
with them because we would like to see
that done so families can re-unite
businesses can uh get together um and
you know people can go traveling again
so uh we we think it's uh it's it's
certainly well due we're we're allowing
americans here we're recognizing their
vaccines and i should mention in this
big change that we're making today uh
another 37 countries uh are also being
recognized by the united kingdom for
their vaccination programs so those
people will be able to follow the new
rules which is you know just a simple
natural flow on day two
to move to slightly more domestic
matters in terms of the the shortages
that we have seen at petrol pumps um the
petrol retailers association have
accused the government of not having the
ability nor the capacity to command and
control the crisis we're 15 days in now
to shortages at the pumps can we put an
end date when are we going to be out of
this situation i understand it's
different in different parts of the
country but it's still pretty bleak down
in this part of it yes i mean government
doesn't have the option it doesn't have
the ability to control um
i mean they're right we don't have a
commander control system over our petrol
fuel supplies and that's probably a good
thing uh what we do know is that in most
parts of the country i was up in
manchester midlands last week uh this
has ended now if you're in london in the
southeast those are the only two the
areas where we're seeing any continued
problems but even there we are starting
to see the plot supplies come through i
know the army are plugging the gaps and
just as an interesting statistic
actually uh compared with the low point
about eight or nine ten days ago
and now there's twice as much petrol in
the four courts underground in the four
courts than there was then uh so
everything's back to normal by this time
uh yeah i think we're right at the the
tail end of this um now and just
again i just repeat there was never
actually a shortage of fuel in the
country in the refineries and the
storage centers
if if somebody says go out and buy which
is what the story we we saw um then
queues are inevitable there's almost
nothing a government can do to stop that
from happening we saw it with toilet
paper well i think the petrol retailers
association would disagree with you on
that one and they would suggest that you
know there have been people in the
industry warning about this problem
coming down the pipeline for for quite
some time just in terms of the reason
that we're in this situation and of
course it is you know shortage of
drivers currently there's a backlog
i believe around about 54 000 hgv
licenses to process and the situation's
been exacerbated by strike action of
course what are we doing to address that
backlog and you know those those hgv
licenses would pretty much start the
problem out yeah let me just actually
nail this entirely for you there are not
54 000 people creating licenses um
there's three and a half thousand people
who have very recently within the last
week applied for provisional hgv
licenses
all of the rest so 52 odd thousand
are people who i've put in for renewals
perhaps address changes the rules are
very clear you don't stop driving for
those reasons so if you if you if you
happen to be an http driver you're
watching this and you've said that
you've moved address for example so
you're one of those fifty thousand uh
it's not a problem you can carry on
driving they will be returned to you in
in time they're processing mid july
right now as you say because of the
unnecessary strikes that were taking
place during covert at dbla it does not
stop you from driving so this is not the
reason for the for the problem and
actually if you want to become an hgv uh
driver uh be very welcome the salaries
have obviously become a lot more
attractive now much more competitive um
you'll actually if you apply for your
provisional license find that turned
around within four or five days so um
but please do apply we're looking for
hgv drivers in this country of course as
is the case worldwide
another topic we need to to dwell on um
there have been hints that there may
well be changes to hs2 coming down the
pipeline perhaps
getting rid of part of the part of the
line going off or prioritizing the kind
of the east to west line what is the
truth of all of this and when might we
get a definitive answer every day that
we that goes past where we're kind of in
this limbo position you know someone
somewhere is going to be losing money
so so uh very simply uh of course we're
building uh hs2 on the west coast um
side um we want to make sure we get the
benefits of high-speed trains
extra capacity really uh from birmingham
uh to leeds as well um and that means
that given that these plans were first
hatched 15 20 years ago even a lot has
happened in the meantime including
northern power including the
conservatives getting elected in 2010 at
minister you know this has been on you
this has been on you know conservative
desks for more than a decade yeah i mean
these are this is a multi-multi-decade
uh project of course
all it's going to say is
northern powerhouse rail that's the plan
to link up lots of northern cities by
rail midlands hub that's the plan to
link up um western midlands east
midlands so we just want to make sure
it's all properly integrated together
there's no point plowing on with a plan
invented in a in a different time and
delivered very very slowly so if
anything what we want to do is speed up
these benefits and find better ways to
to do it and connect uh
yes i was going to say timing wise
obviously we've got the spending review
uh coming up
that is a big moment where the
government sets out its its plans in
this case for the rest of the parliament
uh i think it's due on the 27th of
october to give you a precise date so
not long to wait until we're able to put
all of this into context
i'm just having a quick look over your
shoulders and i can't see a newcastle
united
emblem anywhere there i don't know if
you're a fan but what do you make of the
takeover of the club i understand that
many people dislike mike ashley but
muhammad bin salman you know in his
involvement in the death of jamal
khashoggi which our intelligence
services certainly seem to believe is
the case does mean that we have
some very unsavory people coming in and
taking over
one of the biggest football clubs in the
country what do you make of it well
first of all i mean there's a very clear
test actually it was called the owners
and directors test
for uh football clubs and for the
premier league which they have to
satisfy before anybody can invest in
take over uh a club
they're not human rights experts though
aren't they
no no they're not of course look the
premier league um will need to and has
assessed this the owners and directors
test is the key thing and the point i
was going to make is that tracy crouch
who uh is an excellent mp was a sports
minister is actually carrying out a
review into this whole issue of finance
ownership and the rest of course if
people pass that test as the rules and
the law stands people are entitled to
investing clubs my understanding in this
case is there's been a complete
separation between
the country and the business that's
involved
in so that there's no direct control
i have to confess you're not on my area
of complete expertise but i do know that
the owners and directors tests has to
have been passed otherwise this could
not have uh taken over and i i did note
the fans and seemed pretty uh pleased
about it when i when i saw them
celebrating on the on the tv last night